christian lacroix superstar de la haute
couture il a reçu cet après midi le dé
d'or pour sa collection printemps-été 88
lacroix est ce soir notre invité pour
ceux qui l'ignoraient encore je rappelle
qu'il est entré dans la cour des grands
couturiers en 1987 la croix le surdoué
comme on dit a fait ses classes chez
hermès chez paul a été chez patou ou ses
créations d'ailleurs impertinente et son
imagination ont fait le reste alors
première question pourquoi pourquoi vous
plus que ferrer ou paco rabanne vous
avez fait la différence comment
aujourd'hui dans le moule des d'or
récompense la plus jolie collection de
la saison dont on l'accepté avec
beaucoup de joie
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire quand
vous affirmez la couture doit être un
plaisir épidermique j'ai relevé cette
question tout à l'heure la mode est
quelque chose qui parle de moins en
moins aux cérébrale est de plus en plus
aux sentimentale donc c'est un plaisir
qui doit être quelque chose comme bien
manger bien boire quelque chose d'épique
dermique alors il ya une presse qui vous
qui vous encensent et puis on a une
autre qui vous descend entre guillemets
bon alors oui moi j'avoue qu'on est un
peu déconcerté quand on voit certains
modèles quand même tant mieux tant mieux
je crois que la jeune je cite toujours
monsieur cardin qui a dit que le jour la
haute couture seraient complètement
portable elle serait morte et d'amateurs
qui achètent qui achète vos créations se
reconnaître que la clientèle est à 95%
oui il ya des gens du showbiz aussi il
ya des gens du showbiz là sont des
français en suisse et quelques français
alors on va s'arrêter quelques quelques
instants arrêtons nous quelques instants
sur le travail de prospection des
couturiers la vente au lendemain des
collections dépend du bien vouloir de
quelques milliers de personnes une
clientèle très restreinte pour un marché
de la haute couture qui pèse très lourd
2 milliards cinq cent soixante millions
de francs en quête de yoba grégoire
cette robe de cocktail en coton de chez
nina ricci a nécessité 60 heures de
travail
elle coûte 32 mille francs qui va
l'acheter sans doute quelques-unes des
3000 cliente particulière que se
partagent 22 maisons de couture peu de
françaises
beaucoup de femmes arabes qui feront
leur choix sur cassette vidéo
certaines américaine mais leur nombre
varie selon les fluctuations du dollar
le dollar est base aussi nous devons
choisir maintenant très attentivement
des modèles et surtout ne pas faire de
faute d'une cage presque les vols les
défilés c'est le prestige l'image du
couturier à travers le monde
mais cela ne suffit pas à faire vivre
une grande maison collection comme cette
fusée vu votre 5 et 6 millions le
nouveau fonds est évidemment que tout ça
devrait amortir sur cote 3 ou 400 europe
que l'on vend balaie les voiliers
s'exprimera praticable par contre dès
que vous entrez dans le domaine du
parfum du prêt-à-porter et foulards et
des juifs religieux
c'est d'ailleurs avec ce genre d'article
que la maison nina ricci réalise 65 % de
son chiffre d'affaires
et si on la croit je suis curieux on
peut connaître le prix des deux modèles
que vous présenter ce soir là sur le
plateau je peux vous dire que c'est plus
de vingt-cinq ou trente ou trente mille
francs 30 francs 3000 veut dire aussi
c'est que ces faits à la main donc et
des heures et des heures de travail que
les tissus sont exclusifs qui sont des
tissus créé pour nous et que la
clientèle chez de cette robe est seule
elle est certaine d'avoir elle et elle
seule
c'est toujours le cas sont toujours des
exemplaires uniques avec l'accord des
deux clientes on peut éventuellement
faire deux fois la même robe mais en
principe non alors ça c'est le top
niveau 1 c'est le seul à niveau il y
aura bien lieu le lacroix prêt-à-porter
une diffusion qu'on montrera au mois de
mars
un vrai prêt-à-porter oui alors il
paraît que ceux qui attendent des lignes
un peu baroque vont être déçus vous me
confirmer cette information
peut-être qu'ils seront déçus ce que je
peux dire c'est que c'est un métier
complètement différent c'est à dire que
le prêt-à-porter c'est quelque chose à
consommer tout de suite c'est du
marketing la haute couture c'est un
laboratoire d'idées et c'est plus le
rêve c'est la vitrine passe ici sable
pour un couturier comme nos maisons
n'est pas viable si elle n'a pas de
licence si elle n'a pas de prêt-à-porter
plus tard un parfum mais la plupart des
maisons vides sur le parfois sur les dix
ans et sur le prêt-à-porter
merci on vous retrouve au mois de mars
alors c'est ça mois de mars on le fait
savoir merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation